volvemos para las noticias de economía y
como todos los viernes después vamos con
un tema especial en jorge con que vamos
hoy iniciamos hablando del ha escrito
maneras así es bueno no se puede hablar
de la script o moneda sin hablar de la
más popular y famosa de ellas que es el
bitcoin aunque existen más de 10 mil
cripto monedas en el mundo el bitcoin
vio la luz en 2008 fue difundido como un
sistema electrónico de dinero sin
intermediarios ni intervenciones de
autoridades su creador satoshi nakamoto
o al menos como se hizo llamar es un
misterio sin resolver todavía pero el
cripto activo pasó mucho años en la
popularidad que tiene ahora tomó auge
con la llegada de la pandemia y tras el
apoyo de empresarios como el mosso jack
dorsey el fundador de twitter la moneda
basada en la tecnología de block change
vivió su mejor momento este año cuando
alcanzó los 68 mil dólares y en una
época en la que la mayoría de
transacciones económicas se desarrollan
en lo digital la script o monedas siguen
despertando un enorme interés y
aceptación conversamos antes angela con
miguel yasuyuki hirota él es
especialista en monedas sociales y esto
comentó sobre los riesgos y beneficios
de la script o monedas
cuando pensemos en el caso de la manera
más clásica que es normal la más clásica
que es el bitcoin no existe ninguna
ningún respaldo que garantice el valor
de un bitcoin entonces
hoy en día todo el mecanismo para
determinar el precio de bitcoin está
totalmente completo controlado
por la lógica del mercado de valores o
no por otra parte tengo que admitir que
el mayor con la mayor contribución de
bitcoin vocales cripto maneras es
demostrar que esa tecnología block frame
es completamente viable en la gestión de
un sistema monetario los
ies de ciertas de un sistema más
confiable porque es más difícil
falsificar datos bien y esta semana de
los principales ejecutivos de cripto
monedas se reunieron con el congreso de
eeuu así desangelada y aunque los
ejecutivos le pidieron a los
congresistas normas claras para este
sector económicamente pujante también
advirtieron de que si estas normas eran
rigurosas pues se irían del país varios
analistas afirman que el congreso está
explorando el sector para establecer
normas pero no al corto plazo este año
el salvador se convirtió en el primer
país en adoptar el bitcoin como moneda
oficial y presidente nadie busque e
incluso anunció la construcción de un
acv y coincidí
para ello el gobierno emitirá bonos
bitcoin por mil millones de dólares le
preguntamos a nuestro invitado sobre el
caso específico del salvador y esto fue
lo que nos comentó y para mí es muy
peligroso y me temo a mucho a que es esa
política que no es la política este se
estabilice el sistema monetario hay en
el salvador porque
bitcoin bueno
en primer lugar ver la cotización entre
el dólar el dólar estadounidense que es
otra moneda oficial de el salvador y
bitcoin es muy bueno win es inestable o
sea sube baja como si fuera como
montaner montaña rusa y finalmente jorge
que tan grande es la industria de las
cripto monedas bueno las criptas en
total mueven alrededor de 3 billones de
dólares sólo bitcoin representa el 41
por ciento de la capitalización total
del mercado descripto divisa seguido de
éter um con un 18 por ciento hay otros
factores como
que también hacen lo suyo preguntamos
nuestros invitados en las criptas son
algo de moda o realmente debemos
aprender a convivir con ella y si el
efectivo en algún momento va a
desaparecer en el mundo la tecnología
como tecnología se queda y si se usa en
varias ocasiones pero por supuesto
en el contexto latinoamericano
no creo que desaparezca por lo menos a
la foto plazo todo el efectivo porque
seguramente hay pueblos donde por
ejemplo la luz no en el suministro de
luz es un poco como inestable no
entonces imaginemos en un pueblo
imaginemos de un pueblo donde la luz
bueno sólo no sólo se suministra la luz
durante el día y por la noche hay mucha
dificultad en conseguir larios en este
tipo de lugares no es por otra vía es un
poco conveniente
de aprender al cien por cien de éste se
merece entonces para ciertas
transacciones
seguirá manteniéndose este sistema bueno
en el sistema tradicional de efectivo
llegamos al final sigan con nosotros
i
[Música]